there are more job openings in the u.s
than ever recorded before according to
the labor department the economy had
more than 10 million openings in the
month of june up from 9.5 million in may
and last month linkedin saw a 113
percent spike in job openings in this
country compared with a year ago now
linkedin career expert catherine fisher
joins us now with some tips on getting
the job you want out of that 10 million
that are available uh and catherine i
was really struck by this survey that
linkedin did finding that what people
are looking for is not necessarily pay
in fact that's fourth on their list so
what do they want and how do they get it
so what they want really is flexibility
and what's happened is that over this
last year and a half people have
redefined what's most important to them
and flexibility is becoming the one of
the most exciting things more than pay
yes more than pay health benefits
culture
so this really shows you that this is
why companies are really trying to react
to this so when you're looking for that
job it's going to be really important to
make sure that if flexibility is the
most most important thing to you how are
those companies really addressing that
need of yours i felt that when i was
younger i cared about pay but now when
you get older i do care more about
flexibility in terms of i do think that
that's true yeah maybe they'll move the
hours of this show to 11-1
that would be so great that would be so
great so how do you put a resume
together to get the job you want once
you realize this is it yeah you really
want to lead with those skills so what's
happening is you know companies are
wanting to make sure that you can do the
job but you also want to show those soft
skills so how do you do the job they
they're assuming that if you're applying
for it you you kind of check most of the
boxes so make sure you're looking at
that job description and that you
include those skills another one that
may not be so obvious but is really
important is check for typos you would
not believe how many people have typos
that is your best foot forward so make
sure you're doing everything to look
great what should you leave off the
resume i would say probably uh your
salary requirements and here's another
thing not to do is don't leave just like
a full job description for every
position you've had right what you want
to do is really show like the
accomplishments that you had in those
roles so did you you know instead of
saying i manage the front office you can
say i put in systems that you know
improved productivity by ten percent
that really shows that what the what
you've accomplished in those roles one
of the tricky moments of every job
interview is when the interviewer says
do you have any questions for me yes you
better come up with a better comment
yeah i i never think it's good to say
nope don't have any questions
think of something i've often heard too
that people make a decision about you
the first three seconds you walk in the
door
your picture clips on yeah first
impressions always make a
you don't get a second chance to make a
first impression yes so what's the main
thing you think that grabs people right
away and says i know i like him i like
her it's having really intuitive
questions for the interviewer so making
sure that as you're going in there
they're interviewing you but you're also
interviewing them so they want to make
sure that you're really interested in
this role and want to learn more about
it and i would always ask questions like
how do you measure success you know what
is what are the team dynamics do you
work collaboratively or is it more
siloed work so really probing about what
it's like to work there and then
illustrating the skills that you have so
if you've made it to the interview they
know that you can do the job but really
show examples of how you do that work
so many of these job interviews now are
zoom interviews they're virtual any tips
for handling those because they feel
different you can't make a connection as
easily yeah so one of this is going to
sound awkward but try to make that
connection look at the camera
and you don't want to be like in the
side you know primping your hair that's
a real dead giveaway um so make sure
that you're looking at the camera so
that you feel that connection make sure
that your background is nice and clean
so that it's not distracting because
what you want is you want them to be
focused on your story not what's going
on behind you oh really good advice
catherine fisher thank you so much for
being with us on a hot job market